the jurgen experience in nepal the
reason that you ate a wrath was the
round was considered the strongest
animal
and and uh you weaned kids on it um
because you want the kid to grow to be
strong really yeah and so they would
often wean kids and get a
tiny little piece yeah yeah uh
the cow urine that was the only time i
actually took antibiotics
prophylactically which is something
you're not you're not supposed to do
but i just decided that you know i it
was my second year i didn't want to get
ill
cow urine has some weird uh
pseudo medicinal purposes over there too
yeah they're using it for people that
are that are
suffering from covid and there was uh
yeah there was this like uh
this guy from
i'm trying to remember the country i
don't remember but he was criticizing
like how
ridiculous this practice is of uh giving
cow urine to these sick people how
ignorant
it was well you know it's it's funny you
say ignorant because for me really what
was so important about that experience
was just learning how weird i was
and that is you know um how weird i was
to them
you know and how many different ways
there are to be human
right and so you know um uh
i um uh you know i participated in
marrying off one of our sisters right
because i'm an older brother
a girl 16 you know time to get her
married 16. oh yeah
how old was the dude yeah well you know
people would come by and ask for a hand
this is what the process was and often
bring gifts
and i'm there with the other brothers
and a guy would come and leave and
somebody would say to me well what did
you think of him and the first time they
asked i said
boeing which means what does little
sister think
and people just cracked up and i heard
about that for two years
i would walk to other parts of the
district and people would say oh i heard
about you you're the guy who asked what
boheny thinks
and the point was that wasn't relevant
to them that wasn't what the
experience was right that wasn't a
relevant variable and
you know i i would explain to them that
in my country you actually
chose your own spouse and they would say
well how do you do that
and i say well you find somebody that
you love
and then they would say well then what
if you don't love them
and then i say well there's this thing
called divorce you know
and what i realized was that the way i
thought about how all this should work
was just so
radically different from theirs and not
necessarily better or worse
right their system had its own logic
and it was static it was stable right if
you don't marry for love
right you're not going to get divorced
because you're out of love
right that wasn't the purpose of it the
purpose was it was social it was
familial it had to do with joining
communities
you know and again i didn't grow up
there so that's not what i do or what i
would want to do
but what i learned was how many
different ways there are
to do you know how many different ways
there are to
to be human and always to resist
the automatic assumption that that your
way is the better way
you know because we all do that too and
by the way i did some of that in nepal i
mean you know
one of my other really enduring memories
is my best student
was of the the um the so-called commie
cast which is metalworker which is an
untouchable
um it's way down there right it's not as
low as a shoemaker
and you know they have a cast system
right and at the bottom there
are people that are called untouchables
because you're literally not supposed to
touch them or anything
yes i mean that's how you know
shoemakers especially because
they deal with shoes with cows they deal
with they deal with leather right and
and you know um so why why and
and well because the cow is a sacred
animal right but you need shins
yes you do right and so in the you know
in
the the hindu system evolved to have a
cast that did precisely that
wow right i mean did you communicate
with those people at all
oh sure what was it like yeah they must
have felt terrible
well i mean here's the story the metal
working
family i actually went down to their
house and i had a meal there
and i come back and i tell my amma that
means mother of my family and we were
chatris which is
way up there it's not brahman which is
the highest and
that's the priestly cast but the the
chatris are second
you know they're they were historically
the military cast he's like
babu that means baby which is what he
called me babu you
you you ate rice at a metal workers
house do you know how filthy those
people are
you know what were you thinking and i'm
like listen amma i just don't believe in
cast you know i think everyone's the
same
and p.s you know what's going to happen
i wake up in the middle of the night and
i'm just incredibly ill
and i just go outside and i'm puking my
guts out amma can hear me
he comes from the other room and she's
like listen baboo you can't say i didn't
warn you
you know i mean you know uh and again
you know it was
really useful for me it's not like i
suddenly believe in the caste system
because i don't
right but i think it's really useful
just to have all your assumptions
challenged
you know and that's really what it did
for me and here i was i'm this american
i'm making this great statement about
how all people are equal
well you know what i mean 20 years
earlier in my own country they had a
caste system
right that went back to the 1600s right
and that was the other formative
experience of being in nepal that was
actually the first place that i started
to think about american history
what did you when they were talking
about the arranged marriage
yeah and when you were saying that in
your country people get to choose
yeah like what did you think about
what what is their like how do they
explain it to you
in a way where it made sense did they
attempt to
yeah or did they just say this is how
it's always been well you know
i would say that the things that are
most common sensical to us often we
don't have to explain
right because they're part of our ether
right but i think the logic was this you
know
that um uh you you
you have to create families
right and so you have to yeah yeah
because you've got a
you know you you have to perpetuate the
species right right
and so you know the the simplest and the
most static way to do that is to have
the girls
um uh marry guys
who can who have enough wherewithal to
take care of them
right that can bring you something right
because it's a reciprocal arrangement
right
um and this is one why in rural nepal at
the time
people wanted to have boys not girls
they used to say
chorobastia chorizo which means
the sun stays and the girl goes because
of course the system was also patrilocal
which means that you know you go and
live in the house of
the guy that you've married right so in
the house i live with the older brothers
they all had wives who live there
wow right but when the girls got married
they had to go somewhere else
um so that was yeah well that again and
it's it's ironic because believe it or
not 20 years later i went back to my
village
with with my older daughter who was a
junior in high school at the time
and the three-day walk had become about
a day's walk because they had they had
cut a tractor road kind of up half
half into the mountains and the first
guy that i ran into he just said uh
hey where you been like i haven't seen
you around
they're like oh you brought your
daughter great let's drink rice one
you know and basically you know somebody
had died and
somebody got married and you know
somebody had a kid
but the one thing that was really
different and this speaks to
globalization
is a lot of the younger men had gone to
places like the united arab emirates to
work
you know and that was ironic too because
you know the old story was the sun
stays and the girl goes right a lot of
the suns had gone but they had gone
outside of the country
and that's the way you know so many of
these economies work in in that part of
the world
did you see if the girl's marriage
worked out
well again you know joe it all works out
right i mean you know it works out
because
it was designed for social reasons not
for personal ones
you know it's not about what she thinks
or about what he thinks
uh you know it's about kind of you know
bringing together families creating
communities
bringing up kids it wasn't
about sentiment although you know i i as
i got closer to people
in the community i found out that after
a marriage was arranged
often you did develop feelings for the
person often yeah it's just that those
feelings weren't the foundation of it
right they weren't what spawned it
they were an offshoot of it they weren't
a cause of it did it make you feel
uncomfortable that they were doing that
not in the least you know and in fact i
mean that was when i started to read
history because of course in most parts
of the world including
where we are right now historically
marriage was arranged
but i would imagine that like if you
have this conversation with a feminist
for instance they would have a real
issue with that
and also a real issue with your
acceptance of it right well again
i'm not saying that i accept it for me
right i understand you know
and and uh because that wasn't my
expectation
you know um but you know i i think it's
it's worth asking ourselves the degree
to which
we know we're right right and you know i
think that at the end of the day we
don't
all of us have opinions all of us have
biases all of us have learned certain
things
but learn in hand who was uh you know a
famous
jurist and a federal court judge um
he one of one of the things he said
that's always stuck with me is that
um the spirit of liberty which is really
what we're talking about
is the spirit that is not so sure of
itself
and i've always loved that right so i'm
a human being i have biases opinions
very strong ones
but i think that the worst human
attribute is self-certainty
i think it's the most dangerous one you
know
and uh for me the peace corps was just a
great way to challenge that and to say
okay look i'm not going to have an
arranged marriage and by the way i don't
and i'm not going to marry off my
daughters um
but in another part of the world they do
that um
and that's decreasingly the case by the
way right because these places are
modernized
what the [ __ ] i can just meet a guy i
really
like right and so these you know
i mean when we went back to nepal it in
my village
it was in a remote place so it was
relatively static but there have been
many other changes i mean just think of
all these guys going to the uae to work
on construction sites catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience